because presidential primaries are held
sequentially
people are in the field that they don't
have the results they wanted in Iowa and
South Carolina New Hampshire like like
you back in 2020 like you had a lot of
people who were excited to vote for
Andrew yang
and they voted for you in California or
Washington State or what have you and
you were no longer an active candidate
but they had already voted we had
actually three million votes that were
cast for candidates who had dropped out
by the time they were counted and almost
all of them were cast by someone who
thought the person was still running and
then by the time they were counted they
no longer were so early voting which
creates more access also creates a lot
more chance for basically lost votes and
so ranchers voting would be just a very
straightforward way to give those voters
a backup you know a second or third
choice so that's a really logical reason
for it it's also these crowded fields
are very common and I think the idea of
rewarding a candidate that brings people
together
is particularly valuable for
presidential elections
[Music]
it is my pleasure to welcome the
co-founder president and CEO of fairboat
Mr rank Choice voting himself Rob Richie
welcome Rob thank you Andrew and right
back at you for all the leadership
you've provided for the ranked Choice
voting cause over the last couple years
so thank you I am this awfully generous
because you've been at this since way
before RCB was cool not to put pressure
on you but you co-founded Fair vote 30
years ago is that right yep 1992 and for
uh people who are at least older than 35
or something they may remember that that
was here that Ross Perot ran for
president got 18 percent of the vote
running as an independent and really
created a conversation about what that
means in our political system and we
were working with a guy named John
Anderson who had run for president in
1980 and he had an op-ed in the New York
Times in the first month of our
existence
saying it was time to change our
presidential elections to ranked Choice
voting so we've been at it for a long
time
yeah so 30 years ago uh uh what the heck
were you doing where you were like okay
now I'm gonna start this about this
voting work well I wasn't in elementary
school but I was in my 20s and uh and I
had been kind of a Explorer of how I as
a young man could have the impact I
sought to have on what I felt was a lot
of challenges for the United for the
United States and the world particularly
around ecological challenges I actually
had done a special issue of a
environmental newsletter out in
Washington state about the the challenge
of climate change way back in 91 and and
was was had kind of come to the idea of
voting in politics as a way that with
changes could you know uh Galvanize
government to actually be an ally for
the changes that we needed and that in
turn led to a conversation and
exploration
of why it didn't do so now and and no
way you started out as a climate
activist I was a climate activist before
not also before it was cool
before he did his book Earth and the
bounce yeah no then and that that was a
real concern throughout my my 20s
um you know the ozone layer and and
tropical deforestation and just like
these these issues about sort of like
destruction of the the underpinnings of
the planet I did my uh thesis in college
about environmental ethics and about
sort of what we can do about that and so
that that was not political but my wife
uh Cynthia was involved in politics to
sort of dragged me into politics got me
intrigued with what elections could be
and yeah the the idea of changing the
electoral system right just voting
changing winner take all elections to
some kind of proportional representation
became like really exciting ideas for me
and I reached out pre-internet writing
letters and things to people and um
connected with a core of people and we
ultimately came together and founded
this effort in Cincinnati Ohio in 1992.
uh so let's fast forward to today
because I feel like ranked Choice voting
and fair vote are enjoying a bit of a
moment uh people are figuring out wait a
minute our voting system right now
disproportionately empowers folks who
may not actually have the best interests
of the public at heart or might not even
represent uh frankly the mainstream of
of their community
so fair vote now is a multi-million
dollar organization it has been
instrumental in helping ranked Choice
voting achieve a ton of Victories uh
this past election day it has and we
have a lot of friends and allies helping
us do it which is new as well so for
like the first 25 years we didn't only
work on righteous voting we that was a
centerpiece along with changing to some
kind of proportional representation
those were like the two
foundational pillars of our reform but
we worked on Electoral College reform we
actually catalyzed the eye the idea that
we could have an automatic voter
registration system the I likely like
systemic solutions to voting problems
with sort of the ethos but we did have
this this work on on righteous voting
and in the odds in like the 2000s we had
a string of really valuable City wins
San Francisco Minneapolis Pierce County
Washington you know about 10 15 cities
voted in past Rangers voting and we were
in part of almost all of those and then
we had like a couple setbacks there was
sort of a stalling of the effort and
then in 2016 it passed in Maine
Statewide it's a really exciting effort
there was a really strong local state
group that did that we were the main
outside group to be helpful to it that
kind of just combined with I think the
challenges to our democracy that we were
experiencing at uh a lot of us were were
seen really triggered a whole new set of
players coming in and groups getting
involved and we sort of began to settle
into place where you know different
people are doing different things I
think really leaning into their
strengths so this year Nevada passed
rankers voting Statewide the same model
that it was used in a really impactful
way in Alaska that we can talk about and
that was one where we provided a certain
kind of you know
policy expertise but that was really
driven by other people and hats off to
to the state group that did that to the
institute for political uh political
Innovation the Catherine Gale runs
United America Arnold Ventures big
investors in it provide a lot of
expertise they raised a ton of money
they want a really groundbreaking win we
did a lot more with the city efforts it
was on the ballot in nine cities and it
passed in seven of them cities and
counties and what were the two misses
because I know wait list the seven wins
and then the two misses we've got to
focus on the misses yeah there were a
couple counties in Washington state
where a charter commission had had
recommended it and um I think what we
feel in retrospect is the charter
commission got a little ahead of the
community so it was like a good idea for
that County but there wasn't
the infrastructure of support ready to
kind of pivot into a campaign so it did
lose those two counties but it won in
Seattle it won in Portland Oregon and
one in the biggest County in Oregon
called Multnomah it went in a sprinkling
of other cities Fort Collins Colorado
Evanston Illinois and um all of them had
like really good local campaigns that
were associated with usually with State
groups that have emerged over the last
five six years so we now have groups in
more than 40 States you've got valuable
national players a group called the
ranchers reading Resource Center that
helps on Election Administration and
you've got my wife's group represent
women which talks about what this means
for women in in representation you've
got groups like United America represent
us and you know like like different
players doing doing valuable things and
um so fair vote is I think a
foundational group within that as as a
particular sure particularly valuable
source of policy expertise advocacy
insights and the ability to kind of like
make sure that we're covering all the
bases so like if it's on the ballot in a
bunch of cities we're we're being
attentive to trying to make sure that
they're all getting the resources and uh
support that they need and that's by the
way for anyone watching it's not easy to
just jump in and win ranks just voting
in a state it's not super easy to do it
in a city it's possible though it's that
Margaret Mead quote of just a handful of
people can come together and
um
identify an opportunity and and nurture
it and actually can often create the
conditions for a success so we're hoping
that we can go from about the 60 cities
that are using our CV now to some
version of 500 within three or four
years while we also make progress
higher up but that's something we all
can be part of you not every state can
do it but or you know not every state
allows their cities to do it but a lot
of them do and it's something that's uh
kind of exciting way that that people
can explore getting involved so what Rob
is saying is that if you aren't uh
volunteering in your community the main
character has really happened there's an
opportunity you can do it
the holidays are generally a season of
giving but that shouldn't be the case
when it comes to your internet privacy
and data instead give yourself the gift
of expressvpn so that you aren't giving
away your valuable data to internet
service providers out there we are
passionate about your data being yours I
founded the data dividend project to
help make that happen but the fact is
the big companies still have their run
of of the web that's why I go online
with expressvpn it literally requires
tapping one button to connect and that's
it no matter what device I'm using it
then encrypts and reroutes all my
network data through their secure
servers and you can be sure that your
data isn't being logged by anyone you've
given enough to your ISP this year it's
time for you to start taking so take
back your internet privacy today with
the VPN rated number one by tech radar
and Mashable visit expressvpn.com Yang
and get three extra months of expressvpn
for free that's exp r e s s v p n.com
Yang
expressvpn.com Yang to learn more
[Music]
there's a rank the vote or Pro RCV
organization uh Grassroots effort in a
lot of different places
and they have
frankly a winning argument just about
everywhere they go
because when people dig into it it's
like wait okay my vote will be more
representative of what I really think
there's no more spoiler effect it
encourages positive campaigning and
discourages negative campaigning it gets
rid of runoffs which they're they're
very expensive and time consuming and
energy consuming I mean we're seeing
that in Georgia right now so there are
so many Pros to it uh it reduces
polarization it rewards uh
reasonableness and then the the cons
what are the cons Rob that since you
said all your time championing this well
I think the Rangers voting
is an electoral change that's kind of
like in your face in a sense like some
changes are sort of subterranean like
you change the voter registration system
and you know maybe it helps you get
registered when you move into a state
but you don't really notice that as a
big change right it just happens and you
can look at redistricting and and the
lines are drawn differently in a fairer
way and you might experience it being
different but sort of indirectly like
it's not like you see the lines carved
out on the landscape or something right
just voting the ballot is different like
you suddenly are doing something quite
different you're being able to rank
which by the way is quite empowering
you're no longer limited to just a
single tick on the box right you're
saying here's my first choice and hey I
have a second choice here's my third
choice that's different but it also is
something you have to explain to people
and like how are those rankings going to
be used like you know so so there's like
an educational
um issue not
how to rank but but what it means to
rank right like that's that's the
biggest thing you need to work on and
the candidates
um you know you ran for mayor in New
York City in the system the candidates
themselves need to like learn how to do
this and embrace it or or you know not
feel laid lost because of it because
they didn't know how to kind of run a
good ranchers voting Campaign which by
the way the secret which is really the
shorthand is just try not to be an
[ __ ] but continue yeah
and just talk to more people and listen
to them like that exactly right that's
that's the big secret but some people
think it's you know they they got the
wrong then then the results look
different right so so so you get the
results
you get a First Choice count and then oh
no one wins a majority and then you do
the instant runoff to determine the
winner and the results look different
and say you're really invested in the
outcome
and the results change because of the
system you're like how did that happen
right so so you there there's a
transitional uh Demand with rankers
voting which once done I think settles
into a new reality that people are are
going to love and appreciate and um but
there is a
work work you need to do during that
transition time that I think is
associated with what I guess could be
sent as downsides which is you know you
have to teach people new new ways of
voting and understanding results but hey
that's that's in some ways just a better
form of democracy takes takes takes some
learning
um and it's very intuitive Rob I mean uh
you know one of the jokes I tell is that
I've got two boys who are ten and seven
and they can rank their favorites one
two three pretty straightforwardly uh
and and so when I was in Nevada uh
voters were getting text messages that
frankly struck me as kind of Scare
Tactics where they're like vote no on
three because it's going to be too
confusing and cumbersome
like that's like the the main argument
yeah no yeah it's confusing cumbersome
and then also a transitional thing is
um we have a very
uh inertia oriented electoral sort of
election equipment regime right so when
it it so we have like here we're on the
United States of America like Cutting
Edge technology all kinds of things that
are really
you know moving us forward and the way
we actually count ballots on machines is
sort of this stodgy
regulated poorly administered you know I
mean people are trying to do good good I
work within it but but basically it's
not very responsive to a change so that
when you bring in a new system like
Rangers voting you have to come up with
new processes
that are straightforward technologically
to do and to do it very securely very
transparently but
you have to work within a regime like
say the New York City Board of Elections
which doesn't handle it as well as they
could if if they were running a
different kind of way and that's that's
um that's part of that's part of a
challenge for us too so there was a
snafu in the reporting of New York City
um but let's get specific
so uh What proportion of these cities or
districts that adopt ranked Choice
voting need new machines like can their
current machines actually read a ranked
battle yeah and that wasn't true for
much of our history right so we would
like get the political cell like people
say that's a great idea let's do this
right and so way in the late 90s we had
like Statewide conversations going on in
like Alaska and New Mexico and Vermont
but their machines couldn't do it at
that time so then you say it's a great
idea oh and the price tag is going to be
you have to get new voting equipment and
that was sort of squash the the interest
so then you just had to plow ahead get
your opening wins get that inertia bound
regime to start changing and now almost
every voting equipment can do rangers
voting in from some form or another some
can do it really well so like say uh
Utah cities uh 20 cities in Utah used
ranchers voting last year and they all
had election night ranchers voting
tallies where you could see the status
of the race they still had to count some
more ballots coming in you know for the
next day or two or three but you you
already can see the first ranked with
voting tallies they showed the results
nicely and that was with two of the
biggest uh different voting equipment
was used there and it's just
um we were basically closing out that
barrier
very quickly so we're at at a point very
soon where I think pretty much every
Community will will be able to do
rangers voting efficiently as well
this holiday season give your friends
the gift of knowledge in the form of a
book specifically my book specifically
forward notes on the future of our
democracy which is really much better
than it sounds really really much better
than it sounds thanks happy holidays get
that book
[Music]
foreign
cities over the next uh
three years
um
we'd like 10 Statewide uses of ranked
Choice voting oh I like that and
conversations in Congress those those
are our three big kind of advocacy
oriented goals like serious
conversations and Congress uh so you
mentioned Alaska earlier
um so Maine makes a change in 2016.
Alaska makes a change in 2020 which
means that this was the first cycle and
you saw very dramatic results uh where
uh Mary paltola beat Sarah Palin in my
mind largely because of the nonpartisan
primary and ranked Choice voting process
Lisa murkowski beats a trump endorsed
Challenger that in my mind was strictly
because of the non-partisan it had just
been Republicans Kelly Shabaka defeats
Lisa murkowski and then you have like a
Kelly Shabaka uh you know likely Victory
um but it sounds like it's had even more
profound effects in terms of the way the
the state legislature is now organized
yeah it's fascinating Alaska is a really
some ways an ideal state to be modeling
this form of Rangers voting it has its
majority independent
um and well if you just look at the
simplistic definition of how it votes
for president oh it's just a red State
it's like a independent state right so
they they had an independent elected as
governor in 2014 they had a third party
governor in the 90s they have uh they've
had actually their legislative Chambers
for the last several years at least one
of the chambers has had a bipartisan
Coalition running it so there's a
history of the parties
kind of figuring things out in a more
independent way and the voters reflect
that right so so that they're they're
not simplistic just one side or the
other and which is why someone like a
Lisa murkowski has been able to to win
there even though she lost the
Republican primary way back in 2010 and
then she went as a write-in after after
crazy who the hell went to write in Lisa
William murkowski right and um so this
year the state senate which has 20 seats
uh this Open primary system so this form
of rentals voting everyone votes
in the primary for one person and
they're all running together right so
all the candidates appear before you you
vote for one in the top four candidates
advance and that's when you use rank
just voting in the the spinal vote with
four people and you can put it right in
if if you've failed it none of those
four people really are your Top Choice
and then uh but then use ranked Choice
voting so it's a much more kind of open
process where the general election
electorate which is bigger more full
they're making the final call so of the
20 seats 17 people about equal numbers
of Democrats and Republicans have come
together to form a governing Coalition
so there's only three people
three Republicans including the former
Senate majority leader who just didn't
want to work across the aisle who are
off on one side and basically these
other 17 are going to carve out
committees together kind of work on a
budget together and you know have a
super majority to do things together
they will be certainly a firewall with
any legislative effort that might be
sparked to try to change the system we
now have like a group of people that
want to keep this keep the current kind
of electoral system and um really
remarkable the house is having similar
conversations it's more divided so they
may not have such a coalition but they
might and it's fascinating to see what
that means for governing right right
because that's an expression of let's
let's take the big hot button issues off
the table let's work on things together
that we all agree on and there's some
things that Alaska needs to do together
right because you know it's a state that
has a lot of uh demands it's a huge
State a rural State
um you know a lot of things that needs
to to do well and it now has a you know
a state senate at least and the
incentives for them other people in in
the system to try to try to work
together to get things done
uh people listening to this imagine if
the state
reps in your state just got together and
said hey 85 of us are going to form a
governing coalition
it would be a very very different animal
right and and the thing that's
interesting Andrew is actually our
committee structure historically
before we became a sort of hyper
partisan as we have
the Committees themselves like within
Congress
function that way in a sense so a
committee would have Democrats and
Republicans and occasionally independent
but basically Democrats and Republicans
and they would develop legislation
getting input from both sides rarely did
one side just Jam something through
right so there was like you become
expert in a committee
your expertise is respected you have
hearings you develop legislation
somewhat together right and and so we
actually have a history of that kind of
cooperation
kind of emerging even within a structure
that didn't actually have a formal
um Coalition at the at the highest level
and we've just gotten we've we've gotten
away from that so so legislation is much
more likely to be developed just by one
side often just by leadership and it's
and it's it's and then then you get all
these floor votes where just one party
votes for it and the other votes against
it and it's sort of like a different
world than what we actually historically
have had so in some ways what Alaska is
doing is is creating incentives to bring
back a certain way of working together
to get things done oh yeah man it's like
uh freaking
um call back to some earlier Wobegon
long ago era where like the parties
weren't uh at each other's throats and
people actually just sat down and were
like hey what you know what do you think
would work so you mentioned a goal of 10
states using ranked Choice voting over
the next several years right now we've
got Maine Alaska Nevada just passed it
though they'll have to pass it again
um I'm going to throw Arizona on the
table because I was just there and there
are some folks in Arizona that are very
eager to follow in Nevada's footsteps
what other states do you see as being on
the potential I'm not going to hold you
to it uh list to try and get to 10. well
here's the the caveat to what I was
saying I think we get to 10 by not
only winning uh sweeping victories
basically there are narrower victories
that one can do uh you obviously ran for
president as a Democrat you were
experienced a very crowded field in that
Democratic field
um four states that year the the party
themselves the Democratic party ran
their own contests and used Rangers
voting ballots for that that was Kansas
Alaska Wyoming and Hawaii so those
states did rank just voting contests now
Maine has now voted to pass Rangers
voting for presidential primaries Maine
does it for everything now or all
federal races but that was a State
Legislative action to add it to
presidential election primaries and so
we'd like to see several more States
move toward using Rangers voting for
presidential primaries as an important
logical helpful way to use rankers
voting and that could be several States
and there's that that conversation is
happening in in several of them at the
same time you could have these Nevada
Alaska exciting type ballot measures and
I won't name names actually but there
are you know two three four states that
people are looking at but you know we
have a relatively small field of
initiative States
so that's where you know people can look
on a map and see where the initiative
states are and at least there's a chance
to have a conversation for that and
people are eyeballing what's what's
possible right now well one state that's
a legislative state where it's very much
front and center now is Connecticut
because uh Governor Ned Lamont came out
and said I'm for ranked Choice voting
and so now we're going to see what the
bill looks like
um the the forward party folks in
Connecticut uh are trying to to make
sure frankly it passes
that was super exciting and it's a way
that third parties
um can really you know create a
conversation and they certainly did in
Connecticut and I think there is it's an
actionable follow-up to get some
progress toward ranked us voting now
whether it's all the way or whether it's
a just as a start for something like
presidential primaries we'll um have to
see but but that's some ways getting a
first step
is actually huge because you you then
get the state having it in place so
Maine used ranchers voting at first for
all primaries for state and
Congressional office and then the
general election for congress but it
didn't use it for president they had one
use of it in 2018 and the legislature
said well that worked pretty well and
then they passed it for presidential
elections both General and you know so
once once you get
get a proof of concept you you you have
a greater option and opportunity to take
to the next level yeah that's one reason
I love having it passed in cities
because as soon as the city uses it then
it demystifies it everyone loves it it's
easy and everyone's like okay especially
if it's a big city in a state and then
when the state then is considering it
you've got frankly a lot of people who
are just totally used to it and just say
like obviously we should be using ranked
Choice voting so when you talk about a
state adopting ranked Choice voting in a
presidential primary is that state law
or is that something the party uh itself
can adopt like could the Democrats of
Iowa just decide hey we're going to use
RCV right well there's a handful of
states where the party does its own
contest like Iowa
and of course I had a little bit of
challenge back in 2020 under the DNC
regime
um and that's an example of a state that
could look at ranchers voting totally
driven by the party
but that's only a handful of States so
most States you know basically there's
43 states where it has to be done by
state legislature and then the party has
to agree to use it so there's kind of
like a dance between party and state and
but I think if a state passes a lot to
set it up the parties are are likely to
use it because it really does it's
better for them you know it's better you
know they they get a better nominee they
they make make more votes count I'll
give an a specific example of why it's
catching on for presidential primaries
is because presidential primaries are
held sequentially
people are in the field that they don't
have the results they wanted in Iowa and
South Carolina and New Hampshire like
like you back in 2020 like you have a
lot of people who are excited to vote
for Andrew yang and they voted for you
in California or Washington State or
what have you and you were no longer an
active candidate but they had already
voted we had actually three million
votes that were cast for candidates who
had dropped out by the time they were
counted and almost all of them were cast
by someone who thought the person was
still running and then by the time they
were counted they no longer work so
early voting which creates more access
also creates a lot more chance for
basically lost votes and so ranchers
voting would be just a very
straightforward way to to give those
voters a backup you know a second or
third choice so that's a really logical
reason for it it's also these crowded
fields are very common and I think the
idea of
of rewarding a candidate that brings
people together
is particularly valuable for
presidential elections
okay here's the truth of it I've been a
mattress guy since my 20s I just
logically thought well I'm going to
spend up to eight hours doing something
any money I spend on a good mattress is
going to pay for itself many many times
over and now the mattress that I sleep
on is a helix Sleep mattress in large
part because you can take a quiz and get
a personalized mattress made for you 14
different types to your door and try it
risk-free for three months and then send
it back I know it seems almost too good
to be true but at this day and age and
this is something I definitely didn't
have in my 20s but why get a mattress
that's made for everyone when you can
get a mattress made right for you and
yours American made 10 to 15 year
warranty this is the mattress of your
dreams
and you can get it risk-free Helix is
offering up to 200 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners go to helixsleep.com Yang with
heal Lakes better sleep starts now give
it a try
[Music]
so it sounds like it's up for state law
in in most of these cases you embarked
on this journey 30 years ago thinking
hey we should run presidential elections
via ranked Choice voting uh what are the
steps we would need to take because uh
I've been saying for a while we could be
staring at a trump Biden rematch and a
lot of Americans would look up saying
like hey like what are my other choices
and then the the major counter argument
right now is like oh if anyone else runs
it's gonna spoil it for one party the
other Ralph Nader effect et cetera Etc
um so what do we need to do to actually
make it so Americans could have multiple
choices in a presidential election well
so we talked about the presidential
primaries for the general election
currently that's all done state by state
right so Maine now uses Rangers voting
for president so in Maine
in 2020 you know people ranked
candidates and there was like a green
Party candidate there was a Libertarian
candidate and uh Joe Biden uh actually
got more than half the votes so those
the ballot didn't need to kind of kick
into the second choices but those people
could vote for the green and libertarian
and and not worry about the
quote-unquote spoiler effect so that's
something that each state can do on its
own just using ranked us voting within
the state
there is
um fun ideas in fact I wrote a long
article for the the Harvard Law Policy
Journal about how you can combine State
action on ranchers voting with State
action toward the national popular vote
interstate compact plan that is
established as a way to effectively have
States unite to create a national
popular vote for president and they they
actually could could build
ranchers voting on top of that um and
there's sort of laid that out but that's
that's that's a way that you effectively
could actually have a state driven
process that that allows states to to be
part of a national popular but for
president if we ever want a a truly
United
States of America election
we would need a constitutional amendment
to kind of lock in that will have a
national popular vote and that would be
the time to have a conversation
about how to have the method of election
for President as we change the
Constitution you you can do it with the
national popular book plan sort of state
by state or you could sort of do it do
do it do a kind of this you know
constitutional change which is I don't
think we're very close to doing and and
but that is that's where you
theoretically could do it one thing
that's interesting when you look at all
the presidential elections around the
world and where a lot of countries have
Prime Ministers Who come out of the
legislature but there are a number of
states our countries rather that that
vote directly for president pretty much
all of them do require a majority
and most of them do a runoff election
but like say Ireland has has ranked for
his voting for president and uh but but
that idea of upholding majority rule
that you should get at least half the
votes to become you know the chief
executive is a general principle that's
out there and I think that that
conversation is is an important one for
us to have and partly why we should have
rankers voting state by state for
Governors as well right it's like we
should make sure that the folks who are
you know in that important position of
power uh have done the work necessary to
earn majority support yeah who the heck
wants someone who didn't get 50 of the
vote you know what I mean like and I
mean uh that that's one of the reasons
why Maine adopted it is that you had uh
Governor LePage win without 50 of the
vote they looked around and said well
that's not cool
they had three consecutive governors
one Democrat one Republican and one
independent so conveniently like each
side got got it got a got a chance to
win with less than 40 percent right so
now weighing like 38 36 or whatever and
um at least they're one of those pretty
definitively would not have won in a
head-to-head contest and uh that created
a conversation so it wasn't surprising
that Maine was the first state to pass
it so it sounds like for the
presidential you have this uh
Constitutional Amendment approach uh for
a national election
um or just you get a bunch of States on
board so it's already in effect uh in
Maine
um and so if you had enough States
adopted
um and certainly I'm very very excited
about the state by state approach one
thing I I do want to get into for a
minute is how the heck Connecticut's
Governor wound up endorsing ranked
Choice voting so I tell jokes about this
Rob I said like did he just wake up and
said oh this is a good idea of course
not I mean that's not the way political
figures make these sorts of decisions he
made the decision because he wanted to
win his race against a Republican and
they realized that there was a ballot
line called the grebel frankfur
Connecticut for Connecticut line that
their consultant said was worth about
three percent in the general election
whoever was endorsed by the grebel Frank
party and so how the heck did the grebel
Frank party get that ballot line in
Connecticut
because they ran for governor in 2018
and got four percent of the vote which
is above a threshold to get this ballot
line now Connecticut is a fusion voting
state which means that you you can have
another party have its line but the same
kind of political calculation could
apply in any state where it became a
winning issue where if you knew that you
were going to get even two or three
percent of Voters to vote for you
because you endorsed ranked Choice
voting in Connecticut both the
Democratic and the Republican candidates
for Governor wound up endorsing it
because they were just trying to win so
one of the things that Connecticut
demonstrates is that if you have a
political
interest in being for these reforms then
it can become a winning issue yeah no it
was really intriguing and exciting and I
think shows
the value of having priorities
essentially right you know and and The
Leverage that comes with that right so
so that if any group of people
can prioritize an issue such that they
can say we are going to prioritize this
and our votes are going to reflect it
if it's a good idea or is a reasonable
idea you can find people to listen to
because they are you know even though we
don't have Rangers voting like Governor
Lamont is in a was in a essentially uh
you know
functionally a head-to-head race and and
needed to figure out how how to win a
majority and he needed to kind of like
you know get up to over 50 and then
where you start saying hey I'm I'm only
four percent but I'm part of your 50 you
uh you should listen to what I care
about and that's sort of part of what a
good elected official a good candidate
needs to always be doing right is is
like essentially thinking of these these
voters as a they have a myriad of
interest but I'm willing to kind of like
be a coalitional candidate bringing them
together and that's what politics really
often is and it's okay to be that way
and and I think the Connecticut uh
example is just a really clear drama
dramatization of that all right Rob so
here's an idea where we do it nationwide
check it out
the 2020 presidential election gets
decided by maybe 70 000 votes in four
states uh and the 2024 race will
probably be similar so the four swing
States uh that everyone knows are going
to be very very close are Nevada Arizona
Georgia and Wisconsin those things are
probably going to be within a percent
and then if you were to expand it a
little bit to two percent you end up
including Pennsylvania and Michigan
right uh so it's not very many by the
way no no it shows how messed up our
system is like 44 States uh you're baked
Six States you know maybe might swing
One Direction or another so they have
all the power and the political ads they
can look forward to that but let's
imagine that you got a coalition of oh
let's say 500 000 Independents or swing
voters in those Six States uh to say we
are going to back whichever
presidential candidate comes out for
non-partisan primaries and ranked Choice
voting and maybe let's throw it in there
the fair representation act which you
and I can talk about
you could get this fulcrum because our
country's so polarized and our system is
so dumb
honestly you could make it a winning
issue in the 2024 presidential race
between the two major parties call it
five and six which stands for five
percent in six swing States what do you
think I think that is a potent concept
you just have to find if you can find
those if you if you can find the photos
you can find five percent probably even
three percent but hey five percent's all
the better
who
agreed to prioritize that and it's it's
really challenging for a lot of people
because they can say well I really love
these issues but I care about
something else that's associated with
that party you know
their views on abortion rights or
climate change or you know
economic issues of a certain kind right
like like you have to essentially say
I'm going to make for this election make
those secondary I am going to vote based
on these priorities because if we can
make this change it'll make a change in
our politics that'll allow me to be able
to do Forever After much more of what I
want about all the other things that I
care about so so if you can persuade
people to do that it would be very
powerful right it would be it would be a
foolish candidate
who essentially said no as particularly
I think those issues are good issues
like obviously I'm I'm biased but but I
but I think those issues are ones that
voters would appreciate a candidate
being for right it it is a kind of a
voter's first agenda right which is like
that candidate is standing up for voters
doing the right thing
um and these five percent of people are
are now going to vote for them which you
know if if you do the math if they're
not all from one side right if they're
sort of like include some people who
might vote Republican and some people
who might let's say half and half even
ideally that would be the powerful thing
right if you truly have a certain set of
Swing people that would mean that
whoever makes that position if only one
of them does is getting this boost which
given the way our politics is that's a
huge boost yeah very powerful so Asian
Americans are 9.1 percent of the uh
electorate in Nevada 4.4 percent in
Georgia so those are two states three
percent in the other states uh and they
they tend to be a very uh pragmatic
group uh so not ideological as well
um so I I think you could make this
happen
um and I I may be spending a significant
amount of time and energy making this
happen
five and six yeah no five and six that's
it's a that that that's five and six and
twenty four yeah that that that yeah the
math will have we'll have to work that
out you I could be four and six and 24
and then it would all like be like a
sort of like a product Oh my gosh you're
right because the fact is you're right
that five percent uh isn't even
necessary I mean these versions four
percent if it's evenly divided that does
it like like if you get two percent
Republican leaning two percent
Democratic leaning
that that's enough
so right now people are looking around
saying Okay
um
our our democracy is not functioning so
well uh Congress has a satisfaction rate
of 22 percent last I checked
um but you have these single member
districts and that even if you were to
open it up via ranked Choice voting
um the fact is a lot of the time you'd
still wind up with a Democrat or
Republican winning but there is a way to
a more actually
representative system and it's a bill
sitting in Congress right now it's
called a fair representation act and Rob
and fair vote have been all for it yeah
no it is a truly exciting idea statutory
just an act just an act of Congress but
it is something that Congress has the
right to do Under the Constitution they
have control of time place and manner of
of uh Congressional elections and
interestingly uh over in the early part
of the American history
um States had at large elections for
congress
um a number of them they they were
allowed to under the Constitution and
they said well let's not have single
member districts let's just run
Statewide as the parties took shape
particularly in the 1830s that began to
mean
one party would just win all the seats
right because they they it was like New
Jersey or something would have a
Statewide election and one party would
have a few more votes than the other but
the voters would just vote them all in
and so so it became understood kind of
as an unfair approach um to have these
sort of at large elections so back in
the 1840s Congress using its
Constitutional Powers mandated single
member districts so you had to have one
person per district and um interestingly
that was just at the time with the very
first books literally we're coming out
to say hey there's a different ways of
having elections you can use different
different approaches and there's a kind
of a whole family of systems that are
generally called proportional
representation but it's it's sort of a
loose term that describes basically
something where one side doesn't win all
there there's some way for more of us to
have access to representation and
there's a whole range of ways to do it
as other countries just in the latter
part of the 1800s we're sort of starting
to establish their systems they were
aware of this thinking in different
models and almost all of them actually
didn't use winner Tech all single member
districts they use some kind of system
which wasn't one side winning all
because there's when you think about
what a representative legislature should
be sort of like antithetical to
representation to have a whole lot of
people not get representation and
we have had a conversation at the city
level there are actually a number of
communities in the united states that
don't use winner take all elections and
they they're they're these systems
there's a system called cumulative
voting which is used in a bunch of Texas
cities and a few ones in Alabama and so
on there's there's there's there's
others there's this one that's based on
rank trust voting actually just passed
on the ballot in Portland Oregon so
Portland Oregon is now moving to this
system and we use it in 2024. and in the
Portland system
rather than having one person represent
each neighborhood they'll have sort of
somewhat bigger districts and they'll
have three people so you have more than
one representative have and then but
it's not winner take all so that you
rank the candidates like a typical rank
trust ballot and then your goal is to
use that ranchers ballot to have as many
people as possible help elect someone
the math event works out that about
three quarters of people who can
reliably elect their favorite candidate
or one of their favorite candidates in
every such election and and you apply
that math to Congress so if we could do
this at a congressional level so
Congress is the power and a fair
representation act would be an
expression of how to do this
establishing districts of like three or
four maybe up to five seats that's the
current way that the bill is set up you
would rank the candidates just like you
do in Alaska and Maine but the tally
would be adjusted to basically try to
have as many people as possible help
elect someone and um you would have no
part of the country where there's more
at least three Representatives where
likely one party would win all the seats
so you go to like the bluest of Blues
like you know New York City or the
reddest of Reds in you know rural Texas
or something and you would have
both parties having the election it
would just be two or three Dems and one
Republican or like or vice versa exactly
some degree of openness and the Dems and
Republicans would have differences
within them but furthermore if you're an
independent or a third party candidate
you're never a spoiler right you put
your best foot forward and now you no
longer need 50 to win you can get in
with maybe 20 25 so that you can make
your best case
you can try to win with that percentage
and if you don't win
your second choices matter and they all
know that right and every and all all
the candidates have to be nimble and
building coalitions and um so it just
would mean that you'd have an elected
body
that has shared representation shared
interests in actually serving their
constituents together
when they Retreat to their party
caucuses the whole country stays in the
room and it's just a different way of
doing politics that is within statutory
reach and that's if if if if we could uh
add that to to our mix I think we would
do so much for Congress and by the way
create a whole pool of candidates who
could run for Senate having
better reflected the Spectrum and be and
often run Statewide our current system
is so underrepresentative when
essentially if you're in a red State uh
let's call it Missouri for fun
um Missouri is still probably you know
has like millions of Democrats they're
just nowhere to be found in
there the uh officials they said to
um to Washington
um so the fair representation act would
allow for actual representation and it
would allow for different perspectives
and probably some minor parties to break
through so you'd have some group of
members of Congress who aren't D or R
which by the way would be a godsend in
this political climate because uh uh you
know that that would be a lot of what uh
all Americans want I I think one of the
the supplements to this is that we have
too few members of Congress relative to
the population uh where uh I think there
was something like 80 000 Americans per
representative uh you know when they
started and then now that number is uh
up to 900 000 or something ridiculous
and and we last we used to change the
size of the house every 10 years every
10 years without exception then in 1910
they didn't do it they they couldn't
come to an agreement so then we went 20
years with the same number and then they
just said okay let's just keep that
number so that was like a hundred years
ago over 100 years ago our population
has tripled since then so every district
is now three times bigger than than it
used to be so we definitely are ripe for
a conversation about adding members and
they do go very well together the fair
representation act last I checked had
maybe a half a dozen co-sponsors or
something along those lines and everyone
who's behind the representation Act is
awesome uh because if you're behind it
then you know like you're enlightened
there's some yeah there's some great
folks and I think it's a latent issue
that I think will grow and support as we
have more of a conversation about and
this is a way that people can definitely
help by just giving a heads up to the to
their member about this idea so whenever
they're like saying oh I'm just so
frustrated with with gerrymandering
which they have every right to be
frustrated with gerrymandering this is
like
comprehensive Universal fix right
yeah right you know you just made a
super district and then like you know
you can't really draw on any funky way
exactly are in charge everywhere right
it's just a whole different thing yeah
yeah the fair representation Act is the
closest thing to a silver bullet uh and
most people don't understand it well I
try to explain it to my wife um the
other day and she got it you know I mean
she's very smart but it took me a little
while yeah it was my fault we'll work
and work with you on the tools how to
talk about because it is so exciting but
it is something we need to get down to
uh you know
a bumper sticker that I guess is more
than the name but we have to be able to
sort of say yeah you know you rank the
candidates and it's bigger districts and
you know like like it's you know and
it's like it's a representation like
it's a pie and you sort of cut the
slices and you know whatever we'll we'll
we'll we'll work on it you and I will
Workshop it together
um I genuinely
uh do think that all of this energy
momentum is now gathering around you Rob
and fair vote I hope you hope you feel
good uh you know I mean you've been
working on this for literally decades uh
what are you most excited about upcoming
and how can people help pretty exciting
one as I said earlier it's now not just
fair vote right so there are all kinds
of ways to get involved and great allies
to work with and I really like the way
we're working together with you know
with you and and the people involved in
the Ford party and uh we're really doing
a great job talking about this issue and
you know groups like Rank levod and
these State groups that are emerging
almost everywhere if you go to fairboat
action of which you are a board member
yes board member of Fair Road action
proud to like get involved and you'll
see like links to both National groups
and state groups and um we really are
trying to Channel people as much as
possible into State groups and ideally
then those State groups are creating
their own momentum that will include
supporting the chances that we're trying
to Galvanize around congressional action
and state action of course people can
and we hope will support Fair vote
directly and fair vote action and sign
up and we'll create opportunities for
you to help out um with things but there
really is a nice Spectrum like for
instance
if uh if if you're a college student for
instance like there are now up to I
think we're very close to 100 colleges
and universities where they have gone
through a formal process to change their
student body elections to ranked us
great it's so cool and a lot of uses of
the fair representation act approach
we've got maybe 15 to 20 that do the
proportional system as well and that's
been very organic very and impactful you
know for for for these student elections
though you'll have like 10 15 000 people
vote in some of the bigger universities
that use this system
um your your NGO there's something
called go to rankit.vote and you can
sort of set up your own contest with
rank trust voting um and um so anyway
lots of things to do I certainly
learning about it and helping us figure
out the best way to talk about the
federal Temptation act and so on but it
is something that for my excitement
level I would say
go into this election you know you
always feel nervous right it was on the
ballot in 10 places and some of those
races seem really close a lot of money
was being spent against us in Portland
Oregon say and it just you know didn't
win all of them but we won most of them
and almost every city campaign has won
for five years now we're up to some
version of like 23 out of 25 cities or
something that have voted on it so it's
not a slam dunk but you have to you know
pick your targets but it definitely the
voters like it Rob as soon as you get it
I mean when I was in Nevada too uh I'm
so pumped that Nevada
because both parties came out against it
and again where in my opinion just
trying to scare people uh it was messed
up
um but the the the will of the people uh
won out and when people use ranked
Choice voting they love it you've been
helping make it possible for millions of
Americans you are one of the unsung
heroes of American democracy and if we
make it through this period Rob Richie's
gonna be a big reason why Fair vote Fair
vote action check them out uh again
imagine getting into this stuff in 1992
and uh look at where we are now you've
done incredible work my friend thank you
Andrew and I greatly appreciate that I'm
so excited about where where we are and
where we all can do together four and
six and 24.
four and six and 24. let's go
[Music]